préservez développer la faune et la
flore ce l'objectif de la convention
signée ce mardi 24 octobre dans la forêt
de rambouillet entre le nfl agence
française pour la biodiversité
une toute nouvelle structure créée début
2010 est et qui compte aujourd'hui près
de 1300 agents sur le territoire et donc
mettre en synergie puisqu'on reste deux
établissements publics indépendants l'un
de l'autre mais travailler ensemble pour
mettre en synergie nos compétences pour
en matière de connaissances d'aller à la
rencontre du public en matière de
formation de nos agents tirer aussi les
enseignements réciproque à bénéfice
réciproque si je puis dire de ce que
nous faisons les uns les audaces et
démultiplier l'action
si on imagine pouvoir tout faire tout
seul on passe à côté l'exercice
l'événement a également permis d'exposer
un plan d'aménagement d'une parcelle
forestière dans le domaine de
rambouillet un axe de travail présent
dans les deux structures notamment en
ile de france vous savez que l'un des
grands problèmes de la biodiversité
c'est les ruptures liées parler aux
infrastructures qui coupent qui
découpent les milieux c'est à dire que
c'est pas seulement le fait que la
nature et grèce c'est aussi qu'elle soit
fractionné et qu'elles ne permettent pas
aux animaux espèce de se propager
selon une étude allemande près de 80%
des insectes ont disparu dans les aires
protégées en europe depuis 30 ans et que
la signature de cette convention les
deux structures espère inverser cette
tendance dans les prochaines années sur
le territoire français